[Aplausos]
[Música]
etiopía es un país famoso por ser el
lugar donde nació el café aunque
curiosamente los etíopes no han empezado
a consumir esta bebida hasta hace unos
pocos años lo cierto es que durante
décadas este país estaba entre los más
pobres del mundo pero si seguís visual
politing desde hace tiempo ya sabéis que
etiopía es el escenario de uno de los
más grandes milagros de nuestro siglo
[Música]
exactamente etiopía lleva años creciendo
a ritmos del 10 por ciento interanual-
marcas de ropa como calvin klein o h&m
están empezando a instalar aquí sus
talleres textiles talleres textiles
gigantescos y muchísimas empresas chinas
están montando en las afueras de addis
abeba grandes fábricas muchos ya se
refieren a etiopía como la china de
china pero atentos porque no sólo los
chinos están interesados en este país a
principios de este año 2019 hyundai
abrió su primer centro de ensamblaje en
la zona
en otras palabras que cada vez más
etíopes están saliendo de la pobreza
extrema pero esperad un momento porque
este no es el auténtico milagro etíope
veréis hasta el año 2018 la economía
estaba creciendo pero mantenían un
sistema autoritario al estilo de china
ya sabéis partido único censura y
linchamientos a las minorías étnicas sin
embargo todo esto cambio contra todo
pronóstico con la llegada de este señor
que veis en pantalla
abi ahmed el nuevo primer ministro del
país
y digo contra todo pronóstico porque
había med era general del ejército y
miembro del partido único el frente de
liberación popular que tío pensamos que
todo apuntaba a que este hombre iba a
mantener el sistema dictatorial etíope
tal y como estaba y es aquí donde llega
el auténtico milagro
[Música]
porque nada más llegar al gobierno había
renegado de décadas de autoritarismo y
se ha propuesto convertir a su país en
un modelo de democracia para toda áfrica
de la noche a la mañana ha eliminado la
censura ha prohibido las persecuciones
étnicas perpetradas por el ejército y ha
anunciado elecciones libres para el 2020
por supuesto que todo esto viene
acompañado de reformas económicas y de
un tratado de paz con eritrea que suena
como una música celestial para los
inversores internacionales vamos que si
hay un candidato a premio nobel de la
paz
ese es el señor abu ahmed y de hecho en
visual político ya le nombramos político
del año 2018 pero espera un momento
porque aquí llega la gran duda sobre el
papel las intenciones de este hombre son
impecables si consigue todo lo que se
propone es que a su lado nelson mandela
sería un pringao pero como decimos
siempre en este canal cuidado porque las
cosas siempre son más complejas de lo
que parece
e
el gobernador del estado etíope de amara
es asesinado en un intento de golpe de
estado habéis oído bien las transiciones
democráticas nunca son fáciles y más en
un país donde ya existía una élite
política privilegiada y donde tienen más
de 13 grupos étnicos distintos pensad
que hablamos de un país enorme con más
de 100 millones de habitantes y más de
13 idiomas todo esto supone un auténtico
examen de conciencia para nuestro amigo
había ahmed porque con tantísima
oposición interna y con tantísimos
problemas es muy tentador querer volver
a los métodos dictatoriales a fin de
cuentas para un tirano es mucho más
fácil callar a los críticos así que
ahora la pregunta es hasta qué punto
había me va a mantener su compromiso con
los derechos humanos de verdad puede
etiopía a convertirse en una democracia
o tal vez la tentación de ser un tirano
es demasiado irresistible hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
el país de las tres revoluciones
seguramente muchos asocia es etiopía con
los rastafaris como sabéis bob marley y
sus amigos eran seguidores de una región
que veneraba al rey
haile selassie emperador de etiopía pero
haber sin ánimo de ofender a los
rastafaris que veáis este vídeo la
realidad es que el señor haile selassie
era un monarca absoluto que gobernó
etiopía con mano de hierro sin embargo
ya sabéis lo que os decimos siempre en
visual polític ser dictador gobernante
autoritario monarca absoluto es una
profesión de riesgo así que en el año
1965 la guerrilla de los de erc se hizo
con el poder
[Música]
os podéis imaginar una de las primeras
cosas que hicieron fue matar al rey esta
se conoce como la primera revolución
etíope los der eran un grupo marxista
leninista que gobernó el país durante la
década de los 80 en esos años
colectivizar a las tierras y
nacionalizar a todas las empresas y por
supuesto acabaron con más de medio
millón de críticos conclusión en estos
años es conditio vía sufrió sus peores
hambrunas y así es como en el año 1991
tras una cruenta guerra civil el frente
democrático revolucionario se hizo con
el poder y esta fue la segunda
revolución etíope pero no os equivoquéis
el país no pasó a ser una democracia ni
muchísimo menos este frente democrático
revolucionario era un partido comunista
moderado eso sí con una ideología
similar a la del partido comunista chino
eso explica las relaciones tan estrechas
entre etiopía y china y por supuesto el
crecimiento económico que ha tenido este
país pero atentos porque aquí viene lo
realmente interesante de esta historia
veréis etiopía es un país con más de 100
millones de habitantes y más de 13
distintas tribus étnicas que no se
llevan necesariamente bien entre ellas y
por eso la constitución federal etíope
es tan especial
para empezar etiopía es el único país
del mundo junto a lienchestein donde es
reconocido el derecho a la secesión es
decir que teóricamente cualquiera de
estas nuevas regiones que vicens en el
mapa podría tener un referéndum de
autodeterminación y convertirse en un
país independiente y por supuesto cada
una de estas tribus tiene su propio
partido político todos estos partidos
forman parte de esa gran coalición que
es el frente democrático revolucionario
etíope y todos estos partidos forman
parte también del parlamento en otras
palabras que el debate político en
etiopía no tiene nada que ver con las
ideologías no penséis que se trata de
izquierda o derecha o de liberales
contra conservadores sino que se trata
de distintas tribus defendiendo sus
intereses y diréis ha funcionado este
sistema de verdad es etiopía un ejemplo
de tolerancia entre distintas tribus y
etnias pues lo cierto es que para
empezar este derecho de
autodeterminación que tienen en la
constitución es realmente papel mojado
cada vez que una región ha intentado
separarse del país el ejército no ha
dudado en invadir la y como os podéis
imaginar no
todas las tribus tienen el mismo poder
en realidad de esos más de 13 grupos
étnicos hay tres que son quienes
realmente cortan el bacalao en el país
los aromos los anjara y sobre todo los
tigres el resto de grupos han sufrido
toda clase de violaciones de derechos
humanos eso incluye desplazamientos
forzosos confiscación de tierras y por
supuesto asesinatos en masa porque aquí
tenían de todo
i
por ejemplo los somalíes que viven en
etiopía han sufrido los ataques
continuos de grupos paramilitares y como
os podéis imaginar tanto al gobierno
como el ejército han estado haciendo la
vista gorda durante décadas y como no
podía ser de otra manera miles de
activistas y periodistas han tenido que
marcharse al exilio por si todo esto
fuera poco etiopía también estaba en
guerra con su país vecino
eritrea en otras palabras que si es
verdad la economía iba como la seda 10%
de crecimiento interanual gigantes
empresariales de estilo tipo piano
airlines y montones de fábricas pero la
situación política no podía ir a peor y
ahí cuando pensábamos todos que etiopía
seguiría los mismos pasos que china la
historia ha decidido darnos un plot list
como diría ter y dar bueno en fin la
tercera revolución etíope que ahora
mismo vamos a ver la rockstar y tío p os
lo vuelvo a repetir recordar este nombre
porque puede que sea premio nobel de la
paz dentro de muy poco de hecho ya ha
hecho más méritos que muchos de los que
ya tienen el dichoso premio nobel de la
paz abi
ahmed ali
hasta el año 2018 era lo que en política
llamamos un aparato es decir un nombre
del régimen un general que pertenecía a
la tribu de los aromos que como hemos
dicho es uno de los grupos que controlan
el país sin embargo nada más poner un
pie en el gobierno ha sorprendido a
propios y extraños con un paquete de
reformas que lo flipas lo flipas y
creedme esto de verdad que es algo
prácticamente único en la historia para
que os hagáis una idea en sólo un año
este señor ha firmado la paz con eritrea
ha eliminado casi todas las medidas de
censura y ha acabado con todos esos
ataques a las minorías étnicas os parece
poco pues esperar porque no ha terminado
también ha anunciado elecciones libres
para el año 2020 ha conseguido que
pongan de presidenta a una mujer lo cual
es todo un hito en la historia de la
política africana y además está
aprobando las mayores liberalizaciones
económicas del país
etiopía instalará una red de 4g antes de
la liberalización de las
telecomunicaciones
todo esto es
y entender por qué se ha convertido en
la nueva rockstar africana de hecho ya
se habla de la avi manía y creedme todos
lo que ahora os voy a decir no es
ninguna exageración primero hay grupos
religiosos que aseguran que abby es el
mesías enviado por dios y en eritrea que
hasta hace un año era el enemigo por
antonomasia hay madres que ponen a sus
hijos el nombre del primer ministro
etíope y por supuesto los medios etíopes
están viviendo un auténtico renacimiento
la sátira florecen etiopía hablamos de
periódicos nuevos programas de
televisión nuevos y periodistas que por
fin pueden regresar al país tras años en
el exilio
las imágenes que veis ahora mismo son de
comedias etíopes que se pueden encontrar
en el mismísimo youtube por primera vez
se pueden hacer chistes de políticos o
incluso hacer caricaturas del primer
ministro es más parece que el año que
viene una televisión etíope va a
producir su primer late night al estilo
the daily show todo esto yo os puede
parecer la cosa más normal del mundo en
vuestro país es una novedad histórica en
un lugar como etiopía pero esperad un
momento porque todo esto está muy bien
cuando todos estos medios viven su luna
de miel con el líder que les ha dado la
libertad de expresión pero
y qué pasa cuando empiezan a surgir
críticos de verdad pues atentos porque
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
los riesgos de la libertad como dice el
refranero castellano poco dura la
alegría en casa del pobre y 2019 ha
sorprendido a los etíopes con una
terrible sequía que ha dejado a muchas
regiones en situación de hambruna el
desempleo roza el 20 por ciento y
muchísimos jóvenes están desesperados
por si esto fuera poco la vieja guardia
del ejército etíope no está demasiada
contenta con esta tercera revolución
esto es lo que ha ocurrido en junio de
este año 2019
[Música]
un guardaespaldas mata a un oficial del
ejército etíope ya un líder regional el
presidente del estado de amara fue
disparado y el procurador general
también resultó herido en la capital de
esta región básicamente un militar que
pertenecía a la tribu de los hangares
mató al gobernador de la región en su
opinión había ahmed estaba acabando con
los privilegios de su tribu así que no
se le ocurrió nada mejor que organizar
un golpe de estado para separarse del
resto del país como os podéis imaginar
la reacción del gobierno central no se
hizo esperar y esto fue lo que hicieron
[Música]
a las fuerzas de seguridad etíopes matan
al supuesto líder del golpe de estado
pero no sólo hablamos de una respuesta
militar que en este caso estaría más que
justificada durante casi dos días el
gobierno central corto internet así tal
cual durante varias horas ningún etíope
pudo conectarse a la red de esta forma
no había medios de comunicación que
pudieran contar lo que pasaba ni por
supuesto voces críticas de ningún tipo
en otras palabras que parecía que la
libertad de expresión en este país iba a
durar menos que un caramelo en la puerta
de un colegio pero si pensabais que este
ha sido el único problema para vía web
estáis muy pero que muy equivocados
atentos
referéndum en etiopía docenas de
asesinados en las protestas de los y
damas habéis oído bien con tantos
vientos de libertad en etiopía los
sinama que es una de estas tribus
tradicionalmente reprimidas por el
ejército y establishment decidió
convocar un referéndum un referéndum de
autodeterminación ojo no es que quieran
separarse de etiopía pero quieren tener
su propia región autónoma estos son las
cosas que pasan cuando das libertad a la
gente que resulta que la quieren
utilizar y en este momento es cuando el
gobierno de addis abeba dijo pierre de
verdad que él ya da [ __ ] la hora mira
[ __ ] la hora a viernes en la que te
dio por ese rollo de la democracia y los
derechos humanos y tal con lo bien que
estábamos con la dictadura de veras con
lo bien que estábamos con la dictadura
en qué momento y en qué momento te di a
ti por esta verlos y damas vosotros si
queréis un referéndum un referéndum era
vale muy bien cinco meses podréis
esperar no cinco meses lo decimos más y
como os podéis imaginar este grupo
étnico que quería la independencia los
se llama dijeron
guía
claro
cinco meses saben lo que te digo había
ahmed que tú en el fondo eres como los
anteriores gobiernos mucho y democracia
y constitución vida tenemos una
presidenta mujer pero luego te pedimos
un referéndum y nos vienes con la
tontería está de los cinco meses tú
sabes quién va a esperar cinco meses
había viernes
sabes quiero esperar tu nombre tu [ __ ]
padre va a esperar cinco meses a por ahí
a [ __ ] a la viaje
pues así es como surgieron unas
protestas tan violentas que ya se ha
llevado a más de 30 personas por delante
así que ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
pues si parece que este está la vía es
más decepcionante que la última película
de quentin tarantino pues esperado un
momento porque a veces a veces la
historia es más bonita de lo que parece
[Música]
y tú bien tendrá un referéndum de
autonomía para la etnia sinama en
noviembre exacto parece que había akhmed
está realmente dispuesto a permitir el
derecho a la autodeterminación de los
xiv dama y por el momento parece que la
libertad de expresión se mantiene por
supuesto que ha vuelto internet a
etiopía y mientras preparábamos este
vídeo hemos podido consultar algunos
periódicos etíopes que publican noticias
en inglés y por primera vez hemos podido
encontrar noticias como esta 34 muertos
en los disturbios velocidad más ya lo sé
es una mala noticia una noticia que no
deja en buen lugar al gobierno pero
precisamente el hecho de que un
periódico etíope pueda publicar
las noticias es en sí mismo una buena
noticia por ejemplo sería casi imposible
encontrar algo así en un periódico chino
para que os hagáis una idea
deutsche welle que es como la bbc
alemana ha empezado a emitir en lengua
jara que es el idioma más hablado en el
país y mirad qué tipo de tertulias
tienen en la radio
debate el riesgo del país se empiezan a
oír advertencia de que está en peligro
como país esto justifica miedos de que
el país entero está en peligro de nuevo
no son buenas noticias y tampoco sabemos
a ciencia cierta que se discutirá en
esta tertulia porque lo siento no hemos
encontrado a ningún etíope que nos lo
pueda traducir por cierto que si alguno
está viendo este vídeo y hablan para que
nos escriba pero lo cierto es que parece
que efectivamente hay cada vez más
libertad de expresión en este país y de
hecho había ahmed mantiene su promesa de
convocar elecciones para el año 2020 por
supuesto que esto no va a ser tarea
fácil
de entrada necesita actualizar el censo
electoral lo que implica un trabajo
titánico recordad que por mucho
crecimiento que tengan
etiopía sigue siendo un país
verdaderamente pobre y su gobierno
tendrá que hacer frente a muchísimos
desafíos entre otros el desempleo así
que la pregunta ahora es para vosotros
podrán celebrar elecciones libres sin
problemas en el año 2020 cuántas
tentaciones nuevas le surgirán había
ahmed para volver al viejo autoritarismo
está etiopía realmente preparada para la
democracia podéis dejarme vuestras
respuestas en los comentarios y como
siempre recordad que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros a visual político y darle a
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si se ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]